on March 22nd 2016 two suicide bombers
blew themselves up at brussels zaventem
airport
11 people were killed and more than a
hundred injured Islamic state claimed
responsibility for the attack air travel
has always been a target for terrorism
since aviation began there's been more
than 20 attacks on airports and more
than a hundred attempted airline
bombings and with increasing risk comes
increased security most notably after
the attacks of September 11th airport
security prevented liquids over a
certain size on board they enforce shoe
checks they even started using body
scanners since 911 the positioning of
the security cordon as it were has
really been at that crossover between
what we call the land side of an airport
that anyone can access an air site that
means that anyone entering the air side
area and subsequently going onto a plane
has been scanned searched but what it's
done at the same time is leave large
areas of the airport essentially
unprotected airports in Tel Aviv Nairobi
Mumbai they all have security checks
before entering the terminal building
there are certainly experts who suggest
that all that does is cause large
numbers of people to queue on the street
in just the place where they're
potentially most vulnerable that you'll
simply swap bombings for drive-by
shootings in other words your Creator
bottleneck and that will still put
people at risk there's not only the
question of whether or not you simply
move the terrorist threat to another
area they're also costs involved cost to
the airport's themselves but there are
certainly also costs in terms of time
and the length of the passenger journey
and whether you actually make people not
want to even travel anymore
so no matter what security officials
decide there's always going to be a
toss-up between the need for security
and the hindrance of travel